we got the story from timcast.com
transheiser Bush Michael Knowles details
Bud Light parent companies ties to wef
saying they're mired in World economic
Forum ESG gobble deep he says
transheiser Bush is still scrambling
over the Mulvaney beer can as sales
continue to tank but it's caught between
a rock of customers and a hard place
called g-a-r-m A World economic Forum
backed operation which was subpoenaed
Friday by Jim Jordan and the house
Judiciary here's why one might think
that Bud Light could just apologize in
him if they that men aren't women but no
matter how much Bud Light impairment
company a b inbev might wish to reign in
the radicalism they can't abandon the
agenda they're mired in World economic
Forum ESG gobbledygook he says
Budweiser claims to be a beer rooted in
the heart of America but in 2008 the
Belgian company inbev bought a uh bought
a B for 52 billion dollars putting a
fixture of American culture into a
European rival's hands for the New York
Times now it's beholden to the elites of
the world economic Forum un and EU
Bud light's suggestion the Dylan
Mulvaney endorsement was just some
one-time thing would be more believable
if Abe and bevden openly admit to
wanting to ensure their pro-trans
diversity touched upon all functions
including marketing
he says a B inbev has embraced a Litany
of woke initiatives from ESG to Dei
along with full endorsement of
transgenderism they now foot the bill
when employees choose to mutilate their
bodies so I believe I want to get the
precise language from uh he would say
say we have introduced inclusive
benefits such as gender affirming
medical support for transgender
colleagues in the US and Canada and
financial and legal support for name
changes for colleagues in Brazil and
Colombia so when they say it was just
one can and it was a rogue third-party
marketing let me tell you what they're
really saying first it's not second boy
are they scared they are lying and
trying to pass the buck off in
desperation because 26 drop in sales by
the end of I think it was April what is
it April 15th so we don't even have the
sales data for the for the last the week
after that and the week after that we're
nearly two and a half weeks since those
numbers came out how much you want to
bet it's worse it's becoming a cultural
phenomenon and they are reeling from it
I don't think that I mean the the idea
that that having this gender bending of
of the population popularization of the
LGBT community community that is popular
with a certain segment of the population
but yeah it's a small segment and it
tends to be younger people but to think
that that's going to work with you know
even Millennials definitely not Gen X
not Boomers and Millennials probably
it's still small you you get maybe the
Zoomers but that's about it and so like
Tim had mentioned before uh it boils
down to advertising to kids and your
average person is just like I don't want
to think about that stuff when I'm
hanging out with my buddies drinking
beer I don't want to think about your
political stuff and that's really what
it is it's shoehorning sexual politics
or the politics of sexuality into
everyday life and most people just want
to live their lives and hang out with
their friends and why they take that
shot like why nobody wants it it's not
popular they think there are too many
people
simple as that yes so they're creating a
culture around people having less
children
and I'm fighting that one child at a
time yeah
I'm fighting it right now actively you
want to win the coach awesome you want
to win the culture War you start with
one thing for every kid they don't have
you have two that's it I used to say the
same thing about meat when people would
say I'm not going to eat meat because
it's cruel it's like for every cow you
don't need I'm gonna eat too that gets
really really hard to do I could do it
with maybe like one steak at a time I've
done it just gotta order twice as many
ounces that's it you say is that person
over there vegan I'll get an extra steak
send me the 22 ounces you have to stop
meeting vegans too because eventually
you're going to be eating so many extra
cows it's gonna be too much you're gonna
become just let you eat all kinds
I had a sergeant I worked with and he
would always look at people and he was
like you know you are what you eat and
we're like uh-huh and he was like to
become a tank you must eat a tank and I
was like what are you talking about
you'd always eat like this like you
would shovel things in four like like 90
degrees to his face he's like I know
that's true but I worked but uh but then
when someone starts meatheading like
that they start doing it more and more
they start becoming the tank the more
you eat the meat the more Beefcake you
have to become obviously you know I
watch those videos from fleckis talks
and uh those YouTubers that go to Times
Square and ask questions like name a
country that starts with the letter U
and they're like Utah and you're just
like oh yeah how many how many things
are how many things are in a dozen and
then someone and then the host will just
be like how about the United States of
America and they go oh and it's just
like you have to imagine that Klaus
Schwab is watching those videos too and
he's like don't you get it this is why
I'm doing what I am doing like eliminate
the people there yeah they're they're
malthusian
they they think there's too many people
and so they quite literally want there
to be less of them and
that's a fact does that coincide with AI
to be able to do the the grunt work
because someone's going to still have to
do all the stupid things yes
that Global Elites think there's too
many people Bill Gates talks about it
all the time sure it is also a fact
there is a culture being built around
people not having kids sterilizing their
kids or sterilizing themselves whether
or not those two things are related it's
up to you to decide that's fair did you
ever read Rainbow Six the original Tom
Clancy book you've seen the game
obviously yeah the book itself and this
goes back somebody has to say how long
it goes back maybe they'll tell you in
the chat like what year it was written
but it goes back and it talks about
these Global Elites who want to get rid
of all these people they set up a
utopian set of preserves they bought up
all this land with a ton of money and
then they decide to kill everybody with
a super virus and they almost get away
with it except uh Tom Clancy's rainbow
six guys go kill everybody which is
fantastic but the fact the matter is
this idea has been propagated for a long
time even in pop culture have you played
uh the division I haven't played very
many games in a while the division is a
plague basically wipes out sure the
planet and then the government activates
Presidential Directive 51 creating a
continuity of government and then you're
the division to go in and try and
restore functions and you're like in New
York in the Apocalypse
yeah that sounds like that sounds and
they talk about it sounds prophetic at
this point right talk about operation
dark winter I think it was called
wasn't that uh one of the actual things
that was going on these all these
reveals the massive war game about a
pandemic wiping out the planet or
something like that yeah I think we saw
a very light version in 2020. the only
upside that I ever see about 2020 which
which is minimal because a lot of people
lost a lot of freedom uh a lot of
careers were destroyed a lot of families
uh you know had a lot of Discord and
stuff like that the only thing that I
saw that was good was essentially that
the the ball got moved the goal posts
were moved while people were watching in
real time and they did 10 years worth of
a jump in a few months and everyone was
like oh what are they doing like look at
that look I see it I see them doing it
they saw the game and so some people not
everybody obviously but a lot of people
were able to see that the game has
changed and now they're on to it so it's
a lot harder to pull that stuff off and
they were doing it as a dry run but they
revealed their hand they dropped the
veil and people saw it there's a a
mutual of mine on Twitter he's a New
Hampshire uh
um legislator his name's Mike Belcher
he's at Mike belcher14 and he's got this
great uh theory that Alex Jones can
actually see the future but he can only
see the future when he's looking through
a potato so it's like this crazy weird
way to explain the future but it still
kind of pans out where Alex Jones is
kind of right is it possible that he's
from the future because some of the
things he said to me you know through he
didn't say it to me personally he
doesn't speak in my head although I
would take that that would be fun but
I look at it and I go like I could never
even have come up with that idea his
thought experiments especially about
like time travel and Aliens I go like
that's probably the most plausible thing
I've ever heard it's possible while he
was high hammered it's possible but I
really do like the idea of like Alex
Jones kind of like searing into a potato
yeah divining yeah like dividing the
future exactly like it's the crystal
ball some kind of Irish fortune teller
you see that was you who did that
Sheamus no I don't believe in magic I
don't said anything about potatoes
that's fair that's right you're that's
fair I did make that it could have been
a prophecy yeah exactly that's also true
there are many gifts but one Spirit
right amen what's an Irish witch called
uh I guess a druid
really my buddy would call anybody who
wear a who wears a hoodie a druid he
would yell that at them he's from New
York whenever you'd see people walking
with her Hood down and they would upset
him he'd be like what are you doing you
drew it and people like I was like
that's a very sophisticated you know
sort of insult I'm not 100 sure
they're not associated with that kind of
magic are they uh I'm pretty sure yeah
I'm pretty sure let's go ahead you know
that was all Druids right yeah but I
thought that was more like they came
there astrology well the people who
built it but I think the story was the
Drew has kind of adopted it and started
doing their own kind of thing because
they're like look at these cool Stones
like a Seer we don't have to put
anything up a fortune teller a witch I
don't know if Druids are like looking
into into the future Stones well I got
news for you none of them are actually
looking into the future but I don't know
if I I don't know the Irish ones yeah
the Irish I mean what about Alex Jones
you're debunking the whole Irish had the
gift of foresight you know the world
might look a little bit different
so true
it's like like an 11 layer sort of uh
evaluation in one simple I don't know
yeah Sheamus always tells me that I'm
racist for bringing up these Irish jokes
and here he is he's just going off I'm
allowed to though
no remember when Lance told you what
your ethnicity is
yeah when he said that although I'm not
white I'm white exactly so I'm telling
you although you're Irish you're not but
it's okay because I'm a plastic Patty
too I was born here don't you I've said
this before dude Irish people will be
like ah how can you say you're Irish
when you were born in America it's like
dude I'm not bragging it's an admission
people should know all right ethnically
where my ancestors came from I think I
owe them that dude I'm not bragging
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time